what up space fam goes in here from
anime opera and I am back to talk about
paramecia fruits if you enjoy seeing
these one-piece videos on this channel
and want to keep them coming be sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future want these videos keep in
mind that this is part two of all
paramecia users and their powers
explained as you may know there are a
ton of paramecia fruits so I broke down
this series in two different parts I
said I would do part two after part one
got 5,000 likes and it did so here I am
with the next installment check out part
1 link in the description if you haven't
already as always manga spoilers are
fair game you've been warned now without
further ado let's jump into it first
let's look at the 25 year old and eerily
cute ghost princess Perona
one of Gekko maurya's thriller bark
pirates she ate the horahora know me a
Kade the hollow hollow fruit she can
create ghosts that make people extremely
pessimistic and negative if they pass
through them usually strong willed
fighters will lose the will to fight but
naturally pessimistic people are
unaffected so someone like Oh sob all of
a sudden seems like Superman she can
also send out her own spirit that can
fly pass through things and change size
while her physical body remains unmoved
and unconscious this spirit can also
create hollows that can explode and
physically hurt others by producing
shockwaves the bigger the hollow the
bigger the explosion and damage thus her
spirit can attack others while they
can't attack her unless they find her
real body next let's look at our
resident skeleton Rockstar the 90 year
old skeleton soul King Brooke Brooke ate
the yummy yummy Nomi
aka the revived revived fruit if you eat
this food before you die your soul can
come back to your body after you're
killed this soul lets Brooke animate his
skeleton body like Perona
Brooke can have his soul exit his body
in this state he can move through walls
and survey his surroundings the power of
his soul allows him to use the chill of
death with his sword in this way Brooke
can enhance his attacks in freeze his
surroundings because of his soul powers
he is super effective against the homies
that big mob creates unlike a zombie
Brooke can feel
Payne but his skeleton body does come
with certain advantages like being
resistant to heat cold lightning and
poisonous gas next we have the former
warlord and former Kaito rival the 50
year old gecko warrior captain of the
thriller bark pirates his bounty is a
solid 320 million berries keep the kaga
cog and owe me a key the shadow shadow
fruit his powers let him steal shadows
and create zombies with those shadows if
someone has her shadow stolen and they
come into contact with direct sunlight
it's game over they'll disappear and
their shadow will disappear as well
maurya's own shadow is called Doppel man
and Moria can use it to fight in fact
it's strong it can change shape and it
cannot be destroyed Moria can even
switch places with his shadow when he
wishes to lastly Moria can absorb many
shadows at once in order to increase his
own strength and size if you can't get
enough of this less attractive Batman
then you can check out my video on all
of the Warlord's where I break down
Moria and his powers in further detail
next we have another former warlord the
47 year old Bartholomew kuma
he's the tragic terminator of the series
he used to be human and a revolutionary
but after his Opie cyborg modifications
he seemingly became a mindless slave of
the world government heat the Knik
unique you know me aka the Poppa fruit
Kuma's open hands which have paw pads on
them can push and deflect pretty much
anything he can push the air and use it
as a powerful attack the attack will
move fast at light speed to be specific
and even leave paw prints in stone it's
even more powerful than a cannon these
paw pads can also deflect powerful
attacks including powerful sword slashes
kuma can compress a bubble of air
pressure and create a massive explosion
or he can even push the pain and
suffering out of someone the Terminator
warlord did this with blue fees pain and
Zorro took the impact of it head-on in
order to save his captain you might have
heard of that epic moment where nothing
happened furthermore he can use his
power to push people to faraway lands
and in effect this power is like
teleportation next up we have jewelry
Bonnie a worst generation pirate who
eats like Luffy and has a bounty of 100
million berries she looks 24 but we
can't be absolutely sure of her age
because her fruit lets her manipulate
her age as well as the ages of others
her paramecia fruit hasn't been named
yet the power comes in handy when she
wants to disguise herself and escape
attention but it can also be used in
combat by turning her opponent into a
baby or a really elderly person she can
prevent them from being able to fight
back effectively and it's notable that
she is the only female member of the
worst generation next we have another
member of the worst generation Luffy's
bad boy character foil useless kid aka
Captain Kidd the 23 year old currently
has a bounty of 470 million berries he's
had beef with three young co crews
including the red hair pirates big ma
pirates and beast pirates yet he keeps
coming back for more and now he's even
going to be working with Luffy to help
attack tui on ko you got to respect this
dude's resolve he doesn't care if it
costs him an arm and a leg
as with Bonny's his paramecia fruit is
unnamed his fruit seems to revolve
around magnetism he can repel metal
objects away from himself and he can
also attract metallic objects and use
them to form shapes like that of a giant
metal arm for instance he can deflect
cannonballs and attract surrounding
scrap metal and/or people's usually
metallic weapons depending on how much
scrap metal is available he could
potentially grow his metal arm so that
it is big enough to karate chop a big
ship obviously if there are less
metallic things around he'll have less
material to work with I look forward to
seeing the other creative ways in which
he'll use his paramecia power in the
future next we have the very cool doctor
Captain Trafalgar D water law he's 26
years old and he has a bounty of 500
million berries
he's also much more of a strategist on
the much more straightforward Luffy and
kid
he ate the opieop in know me a Kade the
AA pop fruit we might also call it the
Opie Opie fruit since it is definitely
overpowered law can create a room around
him and pretty much control everything
in that room
the matrix-like room has gotten bigger
in scope since the time skip and law can
do stuff in this room that completely
ignores the natural laws of the world he
can split people's bodies apart in
control to different parts he can attach
their heads to barrels or change places
between
different objects within his room law
can take people's hearts or use his
powers to operate on people he can
practically extract anything from a body
including lead which is how he heals
himself from amberlynn syndrome he can
switch souls Freaky Friday style and
even potentially give someone
immortality but it would cost in his
life because of this latter ability the
Opa Opa Nomi has been called the
ultimate fruit if you want a more
detailed breakdown of law or any other
member of the worst generation you can
check out my all supernovas and their
powers explained video which I'll also
link in the description next we have the
Godfather of One Piece Capone gang BJ a
Mafia don pirate he's 42 years old and
his bounty is 350 million Barry's he ate
the Shia shiranami aka the castle Castle
fruit as the name suggests the user
pretty much turns themselves into a
living castle Capone has his friends
chilling inside him where they're ready
to strike if he needs them he can open
drawbridges from his body and his people
can launch tiny cannon balls at his
opponents of course when they get a
certain distance away from Capone's body
they'll return to regular size
delivering maximum damage you could also
have secret dinner parties inside the
dudes body and he can manifest inside
himself too while his real body remains
inactive on the outside if all that
wasn't cool enough his body can grow
into a giant castle Mecca with
impressive offensive and defensive
capabilities this power is like my
childhood dream having the ultimate
secret fort that you can bring with you
wherever you go and being able to turn
into a mecha next we have Rouge the 47
year old with the 108 million berry
bounty he's called the mad monk and he's
a pirate from sky island interestingly
enough his pirate crew has a cool name
the fallen monk pirates his paramecia
fruit is unnamed but it appears to let
him convert the damage he receives into
strength
kind of like Mele Otis's revenge counter
it's not a super original power but it
can be useful the stronger your opponent
beats you up the stronger you'll become
gurus his body and muscles can grow
until he's bigger than a pacifist ax
even though pacifist O's are tougher
than steel rouge is enhanced
are effective against it which is
definitely impressive I've said it
before and I'll say it again this guy's
a wild card and I really look forward to
seeing more of him even though his
bounty was set to be the lowest of all
worst generation pirates he was strong
enough to beat sweet commander Charlotte
snack who had a bounty of 600 million
berries so don't sleep on my boy Rouge
next up we have the creepy faced basil
Hawkins with his triangle tattoos for
eyebrows he is 31 years old and his
bounty is 320 million berries
Hawkins ate the 100 watt anomie a key
the straw straw fruit despite this he is
not a straw hat but the captain of the
Hawkins pirates his fruit lets him
create and control straw he can create
an army of scarecrows that can shoot
nails at enemies he can also use straw
Budhu to make sure that his subordinates
take any damage he would have taken from
enemy attacks
Hawkins can also surround himself in
straw armor or create a large and
powerful scarecrow which he used to
chase Zorro and Luffy Hawkins combines
his straw powers with magic tarot cards
in battles which can seemingly help him
or hinder him for instance one card may
make his men attack each other while
another may increase the strength of his
straw based technique next we have
scratch Manabu the resident DJ of the
beast pirates he's 31 years old and has
a bounty of 350 million buries his
paramecia fruit powers her music base he
can turn his body parts into different
musical instruments and create music
that will physically damage his
opponents he can rap and his teeth can
even turn into piano keys his music
seems to be pretty entrancing and while
the opponent is caught off guard up who
can create sounds that cut people or
even cause explosions definitely an
emcee to be reckoned with next we have a
former warlord and a best girl candidate
Bowa Hancock the 31 year old sexy snake
Empress has a bounty of 80 million
berries she ate the meadow meadow know
me it gave the love love fruit her
powers revolve around love as the fruits
name suggests and lust boa can turn
those who love her or lust after her
into stone not a good opponent for our
boy Sanji after her victims are
transformed into stone statues she can
end their
career by simply breaking them with a
strike interestingly enough though in
the absence of love or lust boa can
still use physical contact to transform
what she touches into stone these powers
work on pacifist us too it is just the
area she touches that turns to stone not
the whole person or object bull a skill
in combat and her powerful kicks make it
possible for her to destroy the parts of
people or things that she turns into
stone
she's a very impressive waifu who can
flex on multiple pacifist 'as but there
are limits to her abilities even though
boy is extremely beautiful
some people like luffy don't feel lust
and so she cannot turn these people into
stone without contact furthermore people
can use pain to redirect their focus
from their lust which can also help
prevent them from becoming stone statues
and some people like me hawk seem to be
strong-willed enough to be unaffected by
Boas charms blind characters are also
unaffected because they can't see Boas
extraordinary physical beauty next we
have the 47 year old former chief Ward
and up impelled down Magellan Magellan 8
the DOE kudo Kuno me a key the venom
venom fruit Magellan is a poison human
who can create and control poison and is
himself immune to poison this dude can
release poison in the form of a gas or
in the form of a liquid
he can even surround his body with
poison so that anyone who touches him
will be poisoned he can even create a
Hydra made of poison which is pretty
cool if a victim somehow manages to
survive severe poisoning like Luffy did
they can develop antibodies that will
combat poison and venom in the future
next up we have the 53 year old Emporio
Ivanko a commander of the Revolutionary
Army Evon called eat the hood hood or
know me aka the form form fruit and
became a hormone controlling human as he
Von Cove explains that he can freely
manipulate gender body temperature
pigmentation growth excitement and more
Ivanka describes himself as an engineer
of the human body
who can alter people from the inside it
is Ivanka who helped save Luffy from
severe poisoning by stimulating luffy's
natural immunity factors to abnormal
levels
Evancho can use his powers to help
himself in difficult situations or to
help or harm others by changing them
genetic level Evancho can pretty much
give people superhuman abilities next we
have Inazuma the 29 year old
revolutionary who serves under Ivanko
Inazuma ate the chalky truck you know me
I gave the snip-snip fruit which lets
the user turn parts of their bodies into
scissors it's pretty straightforward
Inazuma can pretty much cut anything
solid and then manipulate it like it's
paper and that even goes for ground
itself you know Zuma seems like the
natural enemy of doflamingo strings
however as always see stone is a
different story and Inazuma should not
be able to cut through that next up we
have the man the myth the legend who
blocked an air slash from me Hawk
himself diamond jozu the 42 year old was
the third commander of the white beard
pirates
he ate the kirakira Nomi a key the
sparkle Sparkle fruit this fruit let's
Jose who turn his body into diamond
making his defensive capabilities
probably one of the best in one piece me
Hawk has no problem cutting through
steel but diamond referred to as the
hardest no material in our own world is
another story
not only does Josue block what's
considered to be the strongest slash in
the world he shows no sign of damage
after he does very cool diamond Jose ooh
very cool Blanco is also with the white
beard pirates he's the commander of the
6th division his devil fruit power is
unnamed but it lets him pull things from
pockets on his chin like with page a the
power allows Blanco to pull out things
from his body that should not be able to
fit kind of like another dimension for
storage he's been seen pulling a super
giant mallet from his chin and using it
to flex on Marines he has the kind of
strength
woosah pretends to have with his fake
mallets next let's look at great staff
officer Toru the 76 year old Marine Vice
Admiral sheet the washer washer no me a
key the wash wash fruit Buddha has
explained her power and it's quite
amusing she can wash people and hang
them out to dry as if they were laundry
opponents seem to lose the will to fight
or are unable to fight after this
happens what I mentioned that when suru
uses this power it actually makes the
opponent's hearts cleaner in other words
the power makes them less evil nan
Sara Lee something that pirates want to
go through next we have the Shiki the
Golden Lion another former member of the
rocks pirates along with white beard
Cato and big mob he is the first known
prisoner to ever escape impel down
I usually don't include movie stuff
that's not in the manga and these videos
but Shiki is canon so I'll talk about
the powers he used in the 10th one-piece
movie strong world
he ate the Pawan owe me a Kade the float
float fruit this power lets the user
make nonliving things that he touches
levitate he can use it on himself too
but not on other living things it is one
of the most Opie and versatile fruits
we've seen cheeky can use it to fly or
he can drop unimaginably heavy things on
his opponents he can control the objects
he levitates like telepathy he can lift
many things including water in order to
drown his opponents or even islands
Shiki is clearly a crazy looking mad lad
that you don't wanna mess with next
let's look at Charlotte kata Cody he's
48 years old and he's a sweet commander
with an impressive bounty of 1 billion
berries he ate the mochi mochi know me a
Kade them watching mochi fruit the
translation is pretty straightforward in
this case it's considered to be a
special paramecia fruit and has a lot in
common with logia fruits it allows the
users to transform into mochi not just
to create and control it mochi is pretty
much a Japanese rice cake so the power
goes with a dessert / snack theme of the
big bomb pirates the material is sticky
and can easily change shape so that it's
perfect for trapping people but enough
moisture will make it possible to escape
as with a logia user you need to use
haki if you want to ensure continuity
categories fruit is also awakened and
this allows him to turn surrounding
inorganic material into more Chi to
category and his fruit are so strong
that some fans continue to debate
whether or not Luffy beating him was
believable now let's talk about the
strongest paramecia fruit that was held
by the strongest man in the world the
guru buddha Nomi aka the tremor tremor
fruit it was held by the 72 year old
white beard before he died white beard
had about the over 5 billion at the time
the highest known bounty of any living
character then the hype for the good
we're anomie is off the chart it's been
called the fruit that can destroy the
world and it has a reputation for being
invincible obviously white beard was
eventually defeated but to be fair that
was a combination of old age illness
backstabbing and strong opponent after
strong opponent the power revolves
around vibrations that can travel
through the land air or water these
vibrations are strong enough to create
earthquakes caused tsunamis or split the
ground in half one thing you've got to
keep in mind when using this power is
that the shock waves can be
unpredictable and so you can injure your
own guys but for one guy surrounded by
many enemies this is probably the best
fruit for him to go ham and flex on
everybody Blackbeard stole it from white
beard and now he can use these powers
along with the dark dark fruit powers
this makes black beard deadlier than
ever and I seriously can't wait to see
what he'll do next in the series he's
had over two years to get useless new
power so you can bet that he can use him
more skillfully now compared to when he
was at marine port and that is it for
all paramecia users and their powers
explained part two if you enjoyed this
video the best thing you can do is smash
that like button and share this video if
we can get six thousand likes on this
one
six thousand I will get started on part
three ASAP I'm thinking that I'd be able
to finish all cannon fruits in four
parts and then maybe do a non cannon
special so stay tuned for that if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future want these videos and while
you wait for part three I recommend you
check out my one piece playlist where
you can find hours upon hours of one
piece content just like this lastly the
YouTube ad rates have significantly
dropped recently so the help and support
we're getting from our anime opera
patrons is now more important than ever
a very special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who helped us
survive these YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legend acknowledged by Lord
Twigg o himself
Efrain a and the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans stephen
and rana a lola not end o world stealers
acquire respect potato feh Jonathan King
deci d brandon of isles papa
the school bus emperor otaku and Ritchie
Martinez and our pro hero tier patrons
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson King's eldest Anatoly
kozloski angel Cruz I Sparky 65 cricket
XP Ted no Ted Joel Stanton Mary Gucci
Alicia actor animal 69 Jessica Kayla
Fantine Okami and water Bonnie parks OD
are 12 were Thuan day or Thien Fong
Mitch loves anime cynical Kraken and
JCCC wakka thank you all so much if you
enjoy working at support more read by
going over to patreon calm and me up
poor and becoming a patriot today for as
little as $1 if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to a
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out Pete calm and May out
for a link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see us bass cowboys
[Music]